[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: The
philosopher Joseph Campbell
used to say that when we
are transfixed by beauty,
we are beheld in a kind
of ecstatic arrest.
Right?
We are so transfixed
that we stop breathing.
We well up inside.
We experience what
Camus says as life
lived to the point of tears.
And why do we love these
experiences so much?
Because they arrest time.
They freeze time.
They force us to marvel.
They allow us to become
contemplative beings,
to enter those
head spaces outside
of normal Euclidean
space and time,
and provide a kind of respite
of the human condition.
We temporarily step
off that people
mover that's carrying
everyone else towards death.
And we become gods
outside of time,
reveling in a kind of
ecstatic illumination,
staring into the
sun and being moved
by its magnificent oppulence.
The universe singing
in rapture, and us just
like drowning in it.
It's like the last
scene in the movie
"The Fountain," when he
becomes the bubble that
explodes in space.
There's a kind of mythic
death and rebirth,
this resurrection happening.
We smash our sense of
separateness in these moments.
Yeah, it's kind of wonderful.
I think that's why we do it.
It's therapy.
Awe is therapy.
Inspiration is therapy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]